good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight have you ever noticed
how
nobody in washington can agree on a
number
now math is supposed to be objective
except in oregon where it's racist
but in the real world you would think
that people with functioning calculators
could come to similar math based
conclusions
once in a while but not in dc try
getting a consensus on
unemployment projections or consumer
confidence levels from members of
congress
you can't even get a straight answer on
how many troops will be occupying the
capital three months from now
and that's something they directly
control even allowing for the fact that
most politicians aren't capable of math
it is striking statistics turn out to be
a lot slippier
than they look so with all of that in
mind
it's pretty amazing to watch virtually
everyone in washington republican
and democrat repeat precisely the same
number
on one of the most critical problems
that we face and that number is 11
million
that number they tell us is exactly how
many foreign nationals currently live
here
illegally all the experts say that there
are precisely
11 million undocumented aliens
now 11 million is a lot on the other
hand at a time of trillion dollar
spending bills
is it really so many 11 million isn't
what it used to be
in any case that's exactly how many
illegal aliens there are
11 million 11 million 11 million no more
no less of the 250 million undocumented
people in the world today
the united states has 11 million the 11
million undocumented families
already pay taxes so those are a lot of
the 11 million people we're talking
about right and the 411 million people
is that what we want to do is that the
solution i think
i don't know 11 million undocumented
people
this is america we're not going to go
round up 11 million people
undocumented population has remained
stable at about
11 million for the last half a decade
negatively impacting not just 11 million
people
we have 11 million people here who are
undocumented
as an undocumented immigrant in this
country one of 11 million who are viewed
as criminals
it's almost like a script now people
have different views on what we ought to
do
about illegal immigrants but nobody
questions how many there are because
they're 11 million period joe biden
knows this
he checked with a doctor he lives with
dr jill biden
isn't a practicing physician we
established that after doing a little
shoe leather reporting with our sources
in the medical community
but dr jill isn't noted an
internationally regarded academic
researcher who once wrote a triple
spaced
thesis on community colleges in delaware
so she knows precisely how many
undocumented future americans live here
it's 11 million
she passed on her findings to joe
within 100 days i'm going to send to the
united states congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and all of those so-called dreamers
those daca kids they're going to be
immediately certified again to be able
to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship
now that tape was shot a month before
the november elect
election joe biden then promised to turn
11 million
undocumented people dreamers people with
big dreams into american citizens by
giving them
amnesty and not long after that by
giving them absentee ballots
it was a big promise but joe biden is in
the white house now his party controls
everything
so he can make good on that promise and
he plans to do so in fact it's one of
the very first things he is doing
how's it going to affect you well
according to joe biden's flack
it means you'll have exactly 11 million
new fellow americans
certainly as part of the proposal that
the president outlines and proposed on
day one
is an earned path to citizenship right
for
uh 11 million immigrants who are
undocumented immigrants who are living
in the country
so it's an earned path to citizenship no
big deal they earned it
every bit of it presumably by mocking
the laws of the country they'll now have
a role in running
but actually it is kind of a big deal
adding 11 million new citizens would
have
big effects on america profound effects
how many people is 11 million people
well 43 of the 50 u.s states have a
smaller population
than 11 million that's not just wyoming
and south dakota
it's virginia georgia michigan new
jersey massachusetts and so on big
states
what would this cost no one asked it's
kind of hard to know the real answer but
if you're trying to put the math
together
be sure to factor in the free health
care you'll soon be paying for
every one of the 11 million you support
giving
universal healthcare medicare for all to
people who are in this country illegally
let me just be very clear about this i
am opposed to any policy
that would deny in our country any human
being
from access to public safety
public education or public health period
now it doesn't take an economist to know
that giving free quote health care which
obviously will include gender
transitions by the way
to 11 million new people could easily
capsize the entire us economy
very easily as milton friedman once
wisely noted you can have a welfare
state or you can have open borders but
you cannot have both
yet we're getting both but we may
in fact be getting a great deal more
than that and that's the purpose of this
segment tonight
we all assume that 11 million is the
real number
but is it the real number is that
actually the number of foreign nationals
who live within our borders illegally
and will be getting amnesty very soon
no it's not the real number in fact it's
a totally fake number
which people endlessly repeat only
because they are badly informed or
dishonest
they've been repeating that number for a
very long time more than 15 years at
least
way back in 2005 the pew research center
announced that quote
the undocumented population has reached
nearly 11 million
the weird thing is that 12 years later
pew had roughly the same estimate
nothing had changed in more than a
decade and that should have been a tell
that the number itself was fraudulent in
2018 the problem with homeland security
which
exists to track numbers like these
played along with it and put the number
of illegal aliens in the u.s it's
somewhere around 12 million
right they just made that up watch our
interview from april of 2019 with the
then head of the department of homeland
security
kristen nielsen when pushed nielsen
conceded that
actually she didn't know the real number
she had no idea
does the us government know exactly how
many people were living in this country
illegally i've seen academic studies
that put that number between
11 million 22 million maybe more what is
the real number
uh we debate it uh i mean i think that's
accurate
question we do not know no and um that
must be a grave concern
to you that we potentially have more
than 10 million people
here whose identities we don't know
could be over 20
um whose identities we don't know and
like they could be anybody
yes and so why is that not the single
most
pressing problem the country has in my
opinion
right now this is one of if not the
biggest crisis
this country has faced in a decade
okay so we don't know the question is
what is the real number
and why is everyone saying it's 11
million why is everyone coming to the
same wrong conclusion they're not all
lying
so we checked and here's what we found
pretty much everybody who talks about
immigration including dr jill biden
is using the census bureau's annual
american community survey to estimate
how many illegal immigrants live in this
country
one senior lecturer at mit school of
management put it this way
it's been the only method used for the
last three decades
so what is the method well the census
tallies up the number of foreign-born
people they've identified who live in
this country
then estimators subtract the number of
foreign-born people known to be in the
u.s
legally bingo 11 million that's where
you get
the problem is this method of
calculation
is bound to be wrong many illegal
immigrants don't respond to census
takers
why would they they're here illegally
robert groves the former director of the
census bureau summed up the reality this
way quote
there's no magic bullet that anyone has
discovered to count this population
this is really very difficult to
estimate
oh so many of the studies projected that
there are only 11 million illegal
immigrants have in fact acknowledged
that the census is not perfect they've
been honest about that
but strangely they assumed that it was
pretty close to perfect
specifically they operated on the
assumption that only about 10 percent of
illegal immigrants weren't being
captured by census takers weren't
responding to the forums
put another way their models assumed
that 90
of the people living in this country
illegally were willing to cooperate with
census takers now why would they assume
that
it seems like a ridiculous assumption
but there's a reason
ann coulter explains that reason in her
book adios america which even now is one
of the few serious explorations of this
topic
assuming it's not now banned by amazon
which it may be
it turns out that researchers have been
relying on a 2001 study
20 years ago funded by the university of
california
that survey surveyed a total of 829
people born in mexico and living in los
angeles
and asked them whether they responded to
census interviews
now the majority of them said yes but
here's the amazing thing
nearly 40 percent of those households
refused to answer the survey
at all in other words all the
assumptions that there are 11 million
illegal immigrants in this country are
based on a separate assumption and it's
that
90 percent of illegal immigrants are
willing to cooperate with the census
bureau
and that assumption itself is based on a
survey showing nearly half of all
illegal
immigrants refuse to fill out the survey
this is bad math at the very least
in 2018 researchers at yale and mit
decided to
update the methodology yeah not a minute
too soon
they did not rely on census data instead
they use quote operational data such as
deportations visa overstays demographic
data
death rates immigration rates etc those
are real numbers
they combined them and used a
mathematical model to establish a range
of estimates how many people live here
illegally here's what they found quote
after running one million simulations of
the model
the researchers 95 probability range is
16 million
to 29 million illegal aliens
with 22.1 million as the mean in other
words the estimates that we've been
relying on for decades and repeating to
each other like they're real the
estimates the biden administration is
now using to justify
mass amnesty could possibly in fact may
likely be off by more than 18 million
people there could easily be 30 million
illegal immigrants living in this
country or more
how many people is that that's more
people that live in the entire state of
texas
so how would amnesty for that many
people affect our quote democracy
the one we're all so worried about in
effect it would end our democracy
people who have lived here all of their
lives paid taxes followed the rules been
good citizens
would find their votes diluted to the
point of irrelevance
by the way it would mean an
instantaneous end to african-american
political power that would be over for
good no question about it
apparently maxine waters is too dumb to
know it but that would be the effect
of course it would also ensure permanent
rule by the democratic party
which is the point of it we should tell
you that it's not just yale and mit have
concluded the 11 million number is
ridiculous
back in 2005 bear stearns the bank of
all places reached the same conclusion
bear stearns estimated the total illegal
immigrant population to be as high as 20
million that was 16 years ago
here was their top line finding in that
study quote our research has identified
significant evidence that the census
estimates of undocumented immigrants
may be capturing as little as half of
the total undocumented population
this gross undercounting is a serious
accounting issue
which could ultimately lead to
government policy errors
in the future oh you think like giving
amnesty to 11 million who are actually
30 million yeah that could be an error
now to make this calculation bear
stearns did not rely on census data
because they're a bank they're not as
dumb as our government
instead they looked at bank transfers
remittances from the u.s to mexico
they wanted to capture the number of
payments from illegal aliens living here
to their families back home and here's
what they found
quote the rate of increase in
remittances far exceeds the increases in
mexicans residing in the u.s and their
wage growth
between 1995 and 2003 the official tally
of mexicans has climbed 56
and median weekly wage income is
increased by 10
yet total remittances jumped 199
over the same period how did that happen
well there was no
obvious explanation for this disparity
apart
from a lot more illegal immigration than
the authorities were acknowledging
and then researchers at bear stearns
looked at other indicators
for example they analyze data on school
enrollment and housing permit
applications for multiple dwellings
in one instance they found that some
towns in new jersey reported a
five or six percent growth in population
size at the very same time
the requests for housing permits were
increasing by 600 percent
what quote in major immigrant gateway
cities the influx of immigrants has led
to overcrowded dwellings and a housing
boom
unexplained by official population
growth
happening all across the country our
authorities don't know or intentionally
ignore it
or they lie to us about it again that
was all 16 years ago
and now in 2021 the party in charge is
still assuring us that the number of
illegal immigrants in this country has
somehow
declined by up to 10 million people
could that be true how insulting is that
possible
even to even to float that idea
consider everything that has happened
since 2006 the amnesty for the so-called
dreamers
the promises of mass amnesty the endless
caravan
so the 11 million number is above all a
lie
the 11 million number is one of the more
obvious lies ever told
we're a tv show we're not social
scientists
and it took about an hour to find this
out it's a ridiculous lie
on some level joe biden knows this in
the summer of 2019 he more or less
admitted
the point of amnesty he suggested is not
just to give citizenship to 11 million
people
the point is to import as many new
democratic voters as possible and
there's no limit
watch we could afford
to take in a heartbeat another two
million people
the idea that a country of 330 million
people
cannot absorb people who are in
desperate need
and who are justifiably fleeing
oppression
is absolutely bizarre absolutely bizarre
i would also move to increase the total
number of immigrants able to come to the
united states
he's just throwing numbers out there
they all are they don't know the real
number
they're hiding what they do know they're
cloaking the obvious
beneath more slogans consider how
unbelievably irresponsible it is for a
policy maker another vice president
united states
to start their yeah we'll cover free
health care
for everyone here illegally without even
knowing how many people that is that's
insane
who would do something like that how do
you feel about the country you would do
that to
you of contempt for it of course they
won't tell you the total number
they want you to believe it's 11 million
always in forever and by the time you
figure out they're lying to you it'll be
too late to do anything about it
obviously